income gap I think the to me personally
the income inequality in the in this
country and I'm speaking as someone
who's done very well much better than
anyone thought I'd do in high school and
hi I'm ashamed by the income inequality
in this country and I'm wondering how
can we what can we do
that actually brings back more of a
sense of a middle class because I often
think if these younger people are these
people these poor people that are
disenfranchised if we don't help them
our country just doesn't work well for
the last 35 years the median income that
is the income half way not about average
no average Shakeel you and I have an
average height of what 5 foot 11 minutes
and average is don't tell you much Ryan
median is the most important thing and
the median income for 35 years
has not increased if you adjust for
inflation for most people in this
country and that's where a lot of the
anxiousness and and the anxiety the
frustration the anger has come from and
and it was there before Donald Trump
that was there brewing I remember the
1990s when I was Secretary of Labor all
the you know when you were a secretary
of a cabinet you you know you go to the
the great the great centers of the world
commerce you go to Beijing and you go to
London and Tokyo in Paris but when
you're Secretary of Labor you go to
Toledo or Detroit or you go to you know
and you and talk to average people and I
remember the 1990s people were even
though the economy was good people were
saying you know I'm not getting anywhere
I mean I'm working harder than ever and
I'm getting nowhere and I'm getting
annoyed and the game feels rigged
against me yes they're not a new
phenomenon this has been around around
but it's been growing and by the night
in by night but by 2015 I went out to
some of these same places and people
were saying to me you know something I
am so furious I'm gonna vote I'm trying
to decide between two candidates can't
really decide one of them is Donald
Trump the other is Bernie Sanders and I
said what these people are on different
planets how can you be trying to drive
between there
the common denominator was these people
will shake things up and I want somebody
in Washington to listen to me now I'm
not saying Donald Trump is listening to
them he said he drained the swamp the
swamp is deeper and bigger and broader
and they're more swamp creatures than
ever before but but I think the anger
that he got into office on is still
there yeah and if we don't do anything
about that we're just gonna have more
Donald Trump's you know as far as the
eye can see right or the pendulum will
swing in further extremes one way where
the pendulum nice may swing and further
extremes now again I'm optimistic we
have people more people involved in
politics today than ever before
you know it's the old song it's the old
saw it's only when you are about to lose
something that you value it that you
really understand its value and that's
true of democracy if we don't understand
how fragile democracy is we're gonna
lose it which means that you and I and
all of you and everybody Washington I
really watching we've got to all of us
get involved we've got a vote you hear
me vote
[Applause]
you